et voilà pour ces histoires de poil
alors là nous sommes dans la régie là
c'est vraiment le sacro-saint c'est là
où tout se passe c'est là où toutes les
équipes peuvent accélérer ralentir on
peut parler à cyril il ne répond jamais
et ça c'est la première ligne la plus
importante derrière c'est un petit peu
inutile mais devant c'est extrêmement
important
je plaisante bien évidemment des
relations des prix ce qui hélas
extrêmement important alors noël c'est
le truc qu'ils par exemple nous et ça va
donner tout va bien alors nous il peut
faire des effets ce que fait passer en
noir et blanc par exemple voilà et voilà
la sueur noir et blanc
voilà ce que vous avez des petits coeurs
au ces mignons ces millions 1
voilà c'est sur les effets spéciaux
alors c'est pas non plus du spielberg va
pas se mentir on est quand même dans un
truc raisonnable là c'est pas vrai c'est
pas ou faux peut pas non d'un dinosaure
une cascade le feu appartenant c'est des
trucs un peu un peu basique alors là ici
c'est le real ça va le monsieur réel
bonjour vous allez bien alors je vais me
laver les mains alors ça c'est très
important si on veut faire des grosses
bêtises
là je peux donc changer de caméra là
c'est le plan large
c'est le gros plan et la foule massée
sur le plan large bîmes a placé en
biplace
ben
et voilà c'est très important voilà donc
c'est lui qui va faire madame tous les
plans des chroniqueurs de cyril externe
à côté d'un script très important fred
la scripte c'est la seule qui
connaissent vraiment l'émission dans
cette baraque vous le dis les autres
c'est approximatif elle connaît tous et
très important à la minute où le temps
que celle qui va dire ben on est en
retard
ce don cerib se moquent complètement
comme vous le savez alors là on a encore
des effets c'est un mélangeur il me
semble hélas la personne qui se fait le
plus engueuler dans l'édition c'est manu
manuel en bois avec un expert alex par
non pardon ça va c'est bon alors s'en
foutent façon autour connaît pas le ton
masque alors alex manu jean-pierre ce
pareil alors lui il envoie des musiques
généralement il cherche sur google parle
mais moi un petit bout bah voilà ça
prend du temps
ainsi dans pas mal pas mal mais moi un
petit sur foire et voilà aurait payé
mais tilt et plus réactif quand on est
enfin s'en fait et si ça va mieux alors
ensuite braga talla pour des prises très
important évidemment on prévoit la saga
taxi nous sommes dans la cabine sont ici
on peut changer les voies ben harper on
peut pour se mettre moins graves
regardez ici la voix chez rim sécu
montant voici démission tu dois
descendre tout nu dans le moule si tu
acceptes est ce que remporte cette
mission nous donnerait 20 balles
à mon avis c'est tout ce que vous
conclut merci beaucoup voilà c'est pas
grave on va faire la même chose avec la
boivent jamais quand on est où à part
être masqués par exemple via les cinq
années qui commence par cette année
parmi ces pour les voies et puis on peut
faire partir des musiques évidemment et
c'est ici qu'ont fait tous le mixage son
et j'avais toujours la voie j'avais
toujours la voix je sais la rési alors
que cécile parfois il ya la panique
d'accueil quand ça s'agite c'est ici on
ne vous le savez pas mais évidemment à
un gars bien sûr être en panne et
complètement quand ça se passe pas comme
on aurait voulu tout ça voilà c'est ça